let's talk a little bit about the Star
Trek Affairs of course such a huge
franchise both as a bill man on TV for
many many years what was it like being
part of that you know it was like
Disneyland for actors I got to do
everything I got to stretch I got to
wear crazy rubber costumes I mean really
it doesn't get better than that the only
thing that would be really difficult I'd
say about being on Star Trek is is the
hours I was sleep-deprived for seven
years so and with two little boys
that's serious sleep deprivation
deprivation yeah arrested how you work
no no no what about the memories you had
from those seven years which ones really
stand out for you you know the most
important thing about the show for me
and the most difficult thing to leave
was the fact that we were a tribe we
were we belong together it was it was
more than a family you know it was a
tribe and to leave that was very painful
and I and I miss it to this day and
things like this one of the joys of a
convention like this is getting to see
all my friends what was about here you
think that made her a popular character
and what did you enjoy about her as well
as an actor I enjoyed that she was not
black and white she wasn't the typical
female heroine there was there were a
lot of flaws and there was a dark past
and it made it complicated and
interesting what about particular
episodes that stand out in your memory
over those years probably do it it was
really really difficult to film and we
thought it was a mess and when it was
cut together I thought it was one of the
finest things I've ever been in amazing
is it when you think when you're in the
midst of something it doesn't seem like
it's anything it this certainly all
comes together yeah that's right when we
were doing the pilot I remember just my
head was down because we were working so
hard you had a feeling that this was
something special but until we saw it
all cut together we had no idea would
ask you about Family Guy as well just
again it's such a huge show I mean what
is it you think the appeal of Family Guy
silk has been going number of years now
and what do you enjoy because you have
place with great characters on that show
they do what I enjoy is sad
Seth MacFarland is a genius and you
haven't lived until you've worked
opposite him and seen him go from
character to character to character with
such ease and I've never seen anything
like it I can't imagine I have to say
that it's it's kind of an offensive show
to me it's more of a guy show my husband
loves it and I remember watching there
was a Christmas show and you know Santa
gets killed by the Christmas tree and
the parents come down and they get
killed and and I'm like Matthew I don't
think I can to my husband I don't think
I can watch this anymore it's just too
it's too harsh and the credits were
rolling and he said enough you were the
mother it was a show I had done and I
forgot
so much for being offended brilliant is
that Missy won the highlight see then
that kind of memory yeah yeah it's great
it's great I see my name and I go oh my
god I don't remember filming that one
how do you think we'll see it for many
more years to come and what would you
like to see happen in family guy with
your character is no reason you know I
there are a couple of people in the
world that I would show up for no matter
what they asked me to do Michael piller
who is the producer of one of the
producers of Star Trek was one of those
people and Seth MacFarlane is another I
would show up to do just about anything
he has and what was it like doing the
voice is why did you summon the voice
for Risa Pro that's really likes a
naturalistic style so he likes just
actors doing their thing and so that was
very easy for me I just
he does he does all the craziness I'm a
good straight guy for him